i
[Música]
hola muy buenos días para todos y
bienvenidos a nuestro primer avance de
noticias del día aquí en france24 cerro
blanco y como siempre es un gusto
saludarlos comenzamos en el estado de
florida eeuu donde aumentó a 22 el
número de muertos tras el colapso
parcial de un edificio de 12 pisos en
surfside 126 personas continúan
desaparecidas y se teme que el número de
muertos siga aumentando hoy se inicia el
día 10 de labores de búsqueda y las
autoridades del condado de miami-dade
anunciaron la demolición del resto de la
estructura un segundo complejo
residencial crestview towers fue
evacuado después de que ingenieros se
detectaron serios problemas en su
estructura
recuperamos otros dos cuerpos ahora
tenemos 22 muertos 188 personas halladas
y 126 desaparecidos
nuestros ingenieros y el equipo de
rescate de bomberos están realizando
pruebas y evaluaciones del lugar con el
fin de expandir el área de búsqueda lo
haremos tan pronto como los ingenieros
lo declaren seguro esta tarde firmé una
orden ejecutiva que autoriza la
demolición del resto del edificio por el
interés y seguridad públicos
pasamos a otras noticias el huracán elsa
dejó fuertes inundaciones decenas de
viviendas destrozadas y cortes en el
servicio de electricidad a su paso por
barbados san vicente y las granadinas el
fenómeno natural avanza ahora hacia
haití y se prevé que su impacto se
sienta en república dominicana y jamaica
la noche de hoy sábado 3 de julio el
servicio metereológico de eeuu alertó
que incluso florida podría verse
afectada por lluvias vientos y marejadas
ciclónicas su trayectoria genera
preocupación para el avance de los
trabajos de búsqueda en el colapsado
edificio de sort side
y la costa oeste de canadá continúa
visiblemente afectada por la ola de
calor y ahora enfrenta a cerca de 150
incendios las autoridades intentan
establecer el número exacto de
fallecidos que ya se acerca a los 500
solo en las últimas 24 horas se han
iniciado más de 60 incendios forestales
en la columbia británica que también ha
registrado más de 29.000 relámpagos en
el mismo periodo de tiempo y según las
autoridades estos han sido los
responsables de los incendios
vamos ahora hasta el sur del continente
americano específicamente a venezuela
donde la activista hay un romero
detenido junto al director de la ong
fundar redes abierta a la zona principal
voz de denuncia del conflicto entre las
fuerzas armadas venezolanas y las
disidencias de las farc en una zona
fronteriza con colombia fue liberado
horas después de su arresto varias ongs
venezolanas exigen la liberación
inmediata de los activistas detenidos
entre ellos
tarazona
y en deportes brasil y perú se medirán
en semifinales de la copa américa en una
repetición del torneo hace dos años la
canarinha venció anoche a chile por la
mínima en un encuentro que se definió al
comienzo de la segunda parte con la
solitaria anotación de lucas para que
está el jugador del olympique de lyon
acababa de ingresar al campo y finalizó
una combinación con neymar acto seguido
fue expulsado el delantero gabriel jesús
por rojadirecta y chile buscó sin éxito
el empate antes la selección peruana
había triunfado en los penaltis luego de
un apasionante duelo contra paraguay
ambos combinados empataron a 3 el
término de los 90 minutos en un cara a
cara que terminó con un expulsado en
cada selección hoy colombia se enfrenta
a uruguay y argentina se enfrenta a
ecuador para definir a los otros
semifinalistas
de esta manera llegamos al final del
avance informativo continúa con nosotros
muy buen día feliz sábado
r efe